[Music]
this should be entertaining speaker
Pelosi will be sitting right behind
president trumpet tomorrow of State of
the Union address but President Trump is
putting her front and center when it
comes to blame at the crisis on earth
southern border let's take a look she's
costing the country hundreds of billions
of dollars because what's happening is
when you have a porous border and when
you have drugs flooring in and when you
have people dying all over the country
because of people like Nancy Pelosi
who don't want to give proper border
security for political reasons she's
doing a terrible disservice to our
country it's all part of his message
about Democrats that the president put
out on Twitter last week writing quote
Democrats are becoming the party of late
term abortion high high taxes open
borders and crime here was reaction to
all that and more I can't believe the
first time I've ever interviewed her in
person is Sarah Santos it's great to be
in the swamp well let's start with
immigration what fascinates me the most
is all the Democrats that supported just
a few years ago with Obama president
building a wall funding the building of
a wall and say sounding just like
President Trump it's complete and total
hypocrisy I wish that I could say I'm
surprised but I'm not the Democrats have
been for a number of things not just on
immigration but across the board whether
it's trade infrastructure and the
question is will they decide at some
point they love our country more than
they hate this president and will they
be willing to actually focus on what
they were elected to do come here solve
problems and they're gonna have to
decide to work with the president in
order to do that we've got 90% of our
heroin fentanyl killing hundreds of
people every week crosses that southern
border and the president wants to get
every aspect of the border secure
including building the wall they
supported it at some point though they
own the problems associated with the
southern border crisis a hundred percent
they have to because they're unwilling
to actually fix it and if you're not
willing to fix the problem then you get
to own the problem and so far we have
seen no willingness by speaker Pelosi
and the Democrats to actually work with
the president I've known this president
well before he was president well over a
couple of decades and he
yep pretty much every promise he's tried
and he fights what I told people after
he decided oh they won't even sit down
so we can't negotiate I said a change in
strategy you don't know Donald Trump and
I'm 99.9% certain the person that I've
known for 20 plus years is fairly
tenacious and unrelenting and I would I
would strike that fairly part and just
say very very good and it's a certainty
I mean he hasn't said it if he has to
he's gonna send the military the
military down there now yeah and they
were putting up razor wire what if that
12,000 Caravan goes to an area that is
not secured and decide to just rush
across the border at once it'll be
terrible what disaster rest assured as
this president's gonna follow through
he's done it on every single thing that
he laid out during the campaign he has
been taking things off of that list day
after day after day and this is one of
the biggest priorities the president has
and you can rest assured that he's going
to follow through he's going to protect
our borders he's going to protect the
people of this country he's going to
make sure that he does everything he
possibly can under the Constitution and
under the wall to make sure he's doing
his part and fulfilling that promise
right so we a big State of the Union
speech tomorrow hi widely anticipated
highly anticipated I would expect the
president talks about success president
lays out his agenda for the next two
years and probably challenges that
Democrats basically what you said do
they hate him more than they want to
work for the American people absolutely
they have a job to do the president's
fulfilling his into the bargain it's
time for Congress to step up and do
their part you can be sure the president
will certainly talk about the historic
success that he has had over the last
two years tax cuts the economy I mean
the economy is on fire and that is a
direct result from this president
getting rid of regulations pushing
through the tax cut legislation and
continuing to promote ideas that in an
environment where businesses want to
come here and want to you know hire more
people wages are up unemployment is down
you're going to continue to see the
president push for policies that help
continue the economic boom you're also
going to see the president call on car
and say look we can either work together
and get great things done or we can
fight each other and get nothing done
and frankly the American people deserve
better than that and that's why you're
seeing the president lead time and time
again and call on Democrats to actually
work with him and get things done let's
talk about the Commonwealth of Virginia
and very specifically the governor and
now the lieutenant governor facing
serious assault charges sexual assault
charges where are all those people that
said I believe yeah without any due
process problem we believe that I guess
those accusations if they're against
Republicans I think what has happened
injustice capital yeah absolutely
disgraceful what they did to him yeah
and they did it to Clarence Thomas Rob
in particular Oh every almost every
weekend girls teenage girls were being
drugged and boys would line up in the
hall and gang rape these girls and this
happened for almost every weekend but
nobody ever told the parent of teacher
of policemen it wasn't credible the
beginning now the question is we're all
those people that said I believe and if
they don't say it isn't that hypocrisy
certainly I think what is happening in
Virginia may be one of the most
outrageous things that we've seen in a
long time not just the most recent
discovery of the yearbook but also
governor's comments earlier in the I
guess last week aside I mean literally
making a decision that it's okay to kill
a baby that's already been born I can't
think of that thing during the purring
dilation in other words the birth has
begun Oh will will deliver the baby make
the baby comfortable the mother gets to
decide whether the baby gets any medical
attention and then we'll have a
discussion yeah that's called
infanticide that's killing a kid a soul
an individual that's born that there's
the essence of innocence and that is the
very opposite of who we are as a country
one of the greatest things about America
is that we value life and that we
protect it at every form and the fact
that you have these
individuals who are supposed to be
leaders of our country that are calling
for these types of policies to be
enacted I think it's absolutely a most
grotesque it's gruesome it's evil
this isn't about ad abortion debate this
is about infanticide oh great to see
today so good to see you too we
appreciate you stopping well you have a
hard job I forgot to mention that